yeah all right oh yeah we're ready chair
rash fresh from a very hot Phoenix
it's did you notice that when we got
there we got to our Airbnb we saw a dead
dove and he died from he probably none
of us picked it up
we just left we can try to Mia sores
well I was gonna pick him up with a give
him a proper burial in a plastic bag and
put him in the trash no I said we just
left him there
no one even touch what we're all scared
of it but eyes are though yeah but I'll
split but I up well I thought about oh
maybe those rudd Roadrunners them
there's a bunch of road runners they
don't eat their own bird they'd only
bait insects runners but like like some
could eat it it was kind of an ominous
thing a dove the symbol of peace play
dead
he was dirty though dirty dove three six
three sticks 376 three then Murray three
black men and three white men we we
represent to 182 white men well aren't
two blacks yeah that's I met but I was
taking on Justin Justin too though oh
yeah Justin was there [ __ ] yeah you're
right Justin they all did so great how
about that show the last show it was
Justin how's Justin's last name it was
Moloch how great is that [ __ ] it's
your pal
that's a great shot right there yeah
yeah go go to the one of Chappelle do in
the back flip the picture of my top
right obscene top right that's the
greatest picture in comedy sir
I would imagine so comrades okay look at
Malik's face I told Troy cuz he did the
first show I went dude well next time he
does that make sure you send me a
picture of him with fully upside down
it's gonna be the post of the week man
you got to get it it's so good
desert honey savages desert honey
savages Stevie blue eyes some of the
best shows we've I would say some best
shows I've ever had 100 percent that
early Thursday is a little tough I just
want to do that all the time well the
early shirt well let me just say this
Meyer if you saw me early Thursday and
I'm gonna say it out loud
I've been doing comedy for a long time
some people would say I do pretty well
at comedy some people would say the best
one of the best summer I've heard that
well may you some people would say I
make you laugh hard for a long time
right
I haven't had set that bad in 20 years
even Kobe has an off night I'm telling
you dude yeah I came off but yeah I went
but if I knew something I knew something
was up because Malik starts the show he
might be the best opener our he's a
killer cuz then he's a killer but its
energy so good and subscribe going and
he comes back and I go how is it for
early Thursday you know he hasn't been
doing it that long no and I didn't want
to tell him hey Thursday's are usually
tough yeah even though he's been doing
but sure you know so it's Western
quarantine Thursday's me a little tough
oh yeah so he gets off stage and I go
how are they I could tell you ghosts
they're a little tight but you know they
come around and then then Chappelle goes
out then Chappelle guns backing goes man
how are they is it's fun out there I'm
like fun that's a weird thing I say if I
go out I'm like oh hey dick well I can
tell you came out and I go how are they
they can you go there they're they're
you know they're there they're there
they're out there weird answer I come
out like here goes everybody
huh-huh show early it was the strangest
thing and then we were all a little down
like well and then late Thursday was
crunk of [ __ ] like yeah Kroenke [ __ ] and
how about Saturday night Late Show
how about Saturday for [ __ ] for rock
show how about Saturday war 7 on them
killers kill us it's a great show with
all of us - it was so I want to do that
all the time
Stevie and there's my dick so first of
all we're all swimming and Brian's hey
lingering around just flinging around
waiting in the water we're not stupid
hat and finally I'm saying what
everyone's thinking I oh dude get your
old dick and balls out of our face I
wore hammer and I said him to our sin
stick my stick that's my sensei get your
since then a lot of sin and that old
honey pouch yep out of my face dude yeah
that's and then I said you want stay
there let me get a picture and I posted
that I am disgusted by my body I'm
looking at my torso I'm looking at my
chest my white skin people had a heavy
sack people think you stuffed your boxes
I unfortunately I did he does it and
b-town it has a peak I laugh when we're
naked like like before changes them I
just laugh at your body
you said China's are really like
that droopy dick it's like I got it
weird
sorry I can't okay you came in you just
saw my dick all cuz it was hot and it
was just hanging like it just don't care
like a big old lazy son of a [ __ ]
lollygagging sack of meat in he doesn't
move much he's just a big old dick and
you can't you can't laughing so hard you
got you got a dick and Jay came in and
start laughing you guys just laughing at
my big balls didn't you dick laughing
yeah yeah I do pretty well on that part
but I find that even sure to be so
disgusting bards put damn know girls it
was great it was great
boy oh boy God we had a good time we had
such it's the perfect with Stevie Malik
Jay Chappelle just know that you call
him Malik Modi girl name is Malik Malik
but it's okay cuz you can call him Malik
because that would be like Oh any black
man named Malik is Malik but Moloch his
dad was like now your name is Malik so
tough I know so Maulik but it's just the
perfect combination now he likes it's
like the perfect Lego piece and we even
had a wrestling match to me hold on you
go to Stevie if you go to Stevie's pick
him up Matt Barnes all guys swim party
yeah bro
by the way that looks so incredibly it's
so so aggressively gay how about the
video how about Moloch the best height
man of all time this was this rather you
were dancing like that guy in that video
it was so funny
well people I realize what that video is
[Music]
the manager walked in when we were
wrestling everybody tried to last all on
the first one
Oh was it fry it's Friday night or
Saturday night Friday night Friday night
Friday night wrestling mallet goes oh
dude Friday night is Friday wrestling
night yeah what is yeah we wrestle on
Fridays in the greenroom he goes we did
that in Houston I go all right man i I
want nothing doing so I'm sipping my
whiskey relaxing go to Stevie blue eyes
post he's opposed to the vision boxing
is her life soon I can't live down the
fact that you do with that [ __ ] to him
as a as a wrestler he doesn't know what
to do Don his uh story I put it on my
story too oh you did yeah I just hope
people don't think that he's gotta sit
out here now Brennan here that's the
seat belt oh gosh
God look at that they don't show is
Chappell's tapping himself I was so
worried that you're gonna hurt
somebody's neck cuz you just you know no
look at Stevie to go to him playing them
[ __ ] guitars and it meant I asked him
and why is he wearing a rabbit
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is new her
you're a self-taught all right so when
we're driving back on Saturday night I
go and I go it kind I'd love to learn
how to play the guitar and Stevie goes
dude I'm I couldn't I can't tell you
cause like I don't know like I can't
teach any of that and then she fell just
me neither man we built I just like
learned when I was a kid is that we kept
teacher Mike pop thanks guys I know I
always think back to it I got so I was
signed up to play the piano
take be honest ins at 13 years old and
it was a schedule thing and I just said
no and I should have done it but you had
to have them you got to want to do it or
you don't
dude how much fun look it's just like
how much [ __ ] fun do we have be the
one with Chappelle's and sing it it's
the best
where is rappin you are on stage there
oh no it's so goes between the gloves
first and so I got a voice
[Applause]
yes much let's go me too he's so fun -
ball so much fun I want to do that every
[ __ ] weekend I would die if we did
every week I'm recouping a little bit
cuz I went to bed
see daddy gets all wired up then I went
to bed before yeah I mean I couldn't
sleep I was back up at 8:00 I know what
you're thinking
you only got sleep no I got sleep like
in Laos
so [ __ ] loud and you you wake up at
7:00 no matter what no matter what
because the kiddos about so if I bet at
three for me and three hours sleep I was
so tired
plus you know that that angel heart
whistle ng angels and angels Envy how
delicious outstanding Berman we dressed
in four bottles yeah it's a Kentucky
Bourbon a little hungover I land and got
an IV right away you did right away that
when we have a hard weekend like that I
get to I'd really maybe I should do that
too IV bags and vitamins really yeah who
does that for you I need to do that
there's like connects you the lady you
do that that nad stuff no no nope just
do i replenish nutrients and fluids oh
wow cuz you I think we're not drinking
the fluid no I'm nodding we're drinking
when I try to drink a lot of water yeah
but the IV just you'll feel insulin but
like I feel better today I'm lucky
because I'm able to sleep a lot I just
sleep see I can't can't sleep I go I go
I stay deep if I'm seven and a half
eight hours I'm going hard how about I
only first gun the car to go wherever
we're gonna go to the workout place and
the
the thermometer read 114 or the [ __ ]
yeah yeah how they did we're gonna do a
dry heat III I secretly went and look
for rattlesnakes in the little area
I saw some snake skin Oh huh snakes I
saw Roadrunners for the first time yes
just think kids they don't look like
roadrunner that gets away from Wiley
coyote they're pretty small yeah they
don't have big legs and they're not
friendly no I kinda like the leg up
I like Scottsdale Scottsdale is great ya
didn't get [ __ ] by Kovac did they
don't give a [ __ ] about Kovac Brandon
was flapping his dick oh my god I was
reading well I hear the best shower so I
want to use his shower we had music on
there and then he was reading and the
doors like this and I start flat you get
only too much Julian Rogan I sent it the
worst is rogue alien comet Ronon doesn't
even comment I never I send Rogen
pictures of my dick and he just never
says anything okay it's like come on
dude just it maybe maybe show me your
piece just give it at least give a
thumbs up so I don't feel like complete
[ __ ] moral yeah exactly
I mean nothing but I called it happy
dick Moloch had a big problem with it
cuz I bro I'm [ __ ] trying to take a
nap
you said tomalak right I go I go I go
like this I just sent him that video and
I go cool yeah Malik goes [ __ ] you
Brennan he kept saying like what's wrong
with you is that dick video Mike what
dick videos I didn't know he filmed it
he did I was flapping it it's important
just flapping the way it was good that
was a good piece it was like nice and
nice and flappy yeah that's cool well
done
thanks man gotta do the helicopter
sometimes to death row it's amazing how
immature we are huh
and I have no excuse I'm so much older
than everybody else you're older and I'm
it might be the worst in some ways
hilarious yeah but who cares no it's
still fun and I'm still getting away
with it so we gotta figure out how to do
it again well like we have to figure out
the weight they replenished it reading
every show every show a lot of guys how
about I get all drunk Friday in the
manager what
Rachel Rachel right Oh the bottles empty
hey see what's wrong with issues well
you empty she's all what if they're all
like did you just say it - Rachel you
son of a [ __ ] you tapped the bottle go
this needs to be full tomorrow I was
like she was joking okay you're so good
though huh that's very good angels and
me and the fried rice at that place very
good god it was that it was like wild
rice oh how about your boy Kevin Kevin
Beck Kevin Bayless shout-out to Kevin
man I we did a workout yeah that dude I
love working out with Kevin because he
never hurts you like he just does he
knows exactly how to warm you up and get
you in a workout situation we were at
that gym what was that CrossFit gym we
went to that was good and they were like
all those like competitive weight
lifters were there those CrossFit girls
were insane oh yeah that one isn't hot
we did a lot of [ __ ] yeah anyone got a
personal best I guess she broke some
record of her purse yeah that made me
not like very good and she did that but
very very cute is it yeah I probably
Club hybrid Fit Club yeah yeah he knows
he trains a lot of baseball players but
he knows his [ __ ] he knows his [ __ ] you
know it's fun man any brought don't like
witty the best guy every kid on Sunday
more him for we're leaving he was I
brought you doughnuts and coffee like
he's nineties I'm not gonna suck you off
man he's the best day Kevin's just
[ __ ] I always hang out with Kevin
when I go to super nice guy Arizona yep
oh yeah there's a gray area some stud
too
I gotta look the kid yeah
nice 230 pounds dress well there's a
grand old time wouldn't it I mean ran
ran old on time this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]